en 2017 abdel fattah al sisi conoció por
primera vez a de manuel majo elegido
cinco meses atrás más como fue blando
con el presidente egipcio negándose a
criticarlo frente a la prensa
especialmente sobre los problemas de
derechos humanos una mención que retomó
lecciones de otros líderes sobre cómo
liderar así como tampoco me doy
lecciones a mí mismo
al tiempo varias ongs condenaba en la
peor crisis de derechos humanos en
egipto en décadas señalando detenciones
masivas sentencias a muerte y torturas
extendidas sin embargo egipto es útil
para francia en la región en su lucha
contra el terrorismo además el país galo
se ha convertido en uno de los
principales proveedores de armamento de
los egipcios
la fosa francia ha vendido equipos
militares y de vigilancia a egipto
durante varios años
monge nuestros reportes muestran como
las autoridades egipcias han usado este
material para reprimir a los
manifestantes jugo de tim de
manifestación en enero de 2019
emanuel pajón fue al cairo donde
inesperadamente sí planteó cuestiones
sobre los derechos humanos lo que
disgustó al cis y ahora en esta nueva
visita el presidente francés parece
volver a su posición original tan
criticada por defensores de derechos
humanos yo en condiciones de para no
condicionar en nuestra cooperación en
defensa y economía a esos desacuerdos
primero porque creo en la soberanía
nacional y al respeto por nuestro
interés legítimo y recíproco
segundo porque creo que es más eficiente
tener una política que demande diálogo a
una política del boicot lo que reduciría
la efectividad de nuestro socio en la
lucha contra el terrorismo y la
estabilidad regional oeste billy y
regional
sería en efectivo en materia de derechos
humanos y contraproducente en la lucha
contra
terrorismo contigo mismo justo antes de
la llegada de al sisi a parís el domingo
egipto liberó a tres trabajadores
humanitarios se estima que 60 mil
detenidos en egipto son prisioneros
políticos